Hai, nama saya Katy Beslado,
saya direktur strategi IBM Quantum
dan riset aplikasi. Saya di sini untuk meluruskan
sebanyak mungkin mitos komputasi kuantum
dalam enam puluh detik.
Komputer kuantum itu benar-benar nyata,
dan kita punya perangkat di IBM Cloud yang bisa diakses siapa saja sekarang.
Ya, tapi hanya untuk hal-hal tertentu yang memang jago mereka kerjakan,
yaitu matematika super kompleks seperti yang mendasari alam semesta.
Tapi kalau mau bikin spreadsheet atau kirim email, pakai saja
PC kamu.
Secara teori bisa, tapi tidak
dalam waktu dekat. Belum ada yang bikin komputer cukup canggih untuk itu
saat ini. Untuk masa mendatang yang bisa diprediksi, kita masih on track,
dan ketika kita sampai ke sana, kita akan mengubah cara kita melindungi
informasi.
Itu sepenuhnya salah. Komputer kuantum
secara fundamental berbeda
dan menggunakan hukum alam untuk memproses informasi.
AI masa kini berjalan di perangkat klasik yang sudah lama ada,
tapi kita percaya mereka akan berkolaborasi di masa depan.
Tidak benar. Kita punya ekosistem yang luar biasa
dari startup, akademisi, laboratorium nasional, dan mitra industri yang
menggunakan perangkat kita setiap hari.
Tidak. Komputasi terinspirasi-kuantum sudah ada
sejak lama dan berjalan di perangkat klasik. Mereka
tidak akan pernah memenuhi janji komputasi kuantum.
Kalau kamu mau komputasi kuantum, kamu harus melakukannya dengan komputer kuantum sungguhan.
Komputer kuantum sungguhan.